[Musique]
le bonheur au travail ce n'est pas
nouveau
dès 1912 l'article l 47 41 tirs et 1 du
code du travail stipule clairement que
c'est à l'employeur de protéger la santé
physique et psychique de ses salariés
mais il faudra attendre les années 60
pour que les fat qu'on s'empare de la
question
l'apparition des machines à café est la
première étape vers le bien-être au
turbin une révolution et distributeurs
automatiques ont fait leur apparition
un bouton a tourné et la machine débite
un gobelet et la boisson désiré chaudes
ou froides s'est lu même coup l'occasion
d'une courte détente musique douce et
verre en main le fera bientôt admettre
que le travail est un plaisir le travail
c'est la santé dans les sixties les
employeurs prennent l'adage à la lettre
et révolutionne l'organisation du
travail en intégrant le sport dans les
plannings
le soir les galeries lafayette propose
des activités sportives à leurs salariés
le choix est vaste il va du judo à la
gym en passant par la natation troqué
samedi quand même que je sois fatigué le
fait souvent il soit par suivait tout
certain
c'est pendant les heures de travail
qu'on des chouchoutes avec
l'instauration de pause relaxation un
concept venu de scandinavie
un objectif d'étendre nos muscles
malmené par les cadences infernales du
travail à la chaîne
chacun a la possibilité de pratiquer la
gymnastique de pause qui fait travailler
les muscles non sollicitée par
l'activité professionnelle
certaines administrations la pratique
quotidiennement
[Musique]
tous ces exercices concours efficacement
à éliminer la fatigue et la productivité
s'en est trouvée sensiblement améliorée
tout est fait pour que le salarié soit
heureux
une idée de file entrant pas vraiment si
l'objectif affiché le bien-être des
équipes la relaxation au travail c'est
gagnant gagnant
un employé épanouie c'est un employé
efficaces comme le souligne et déjà
cette responsable bien avant de faire de
pratiquer la gymnastique de pau zone
atelier nous avions de nombreuses verra
trices qui manquait une journée deux
jours ou des raisons futiles
en fait depuis que nous pratiquons sur
jean le style de pause
nous n'avons plus que les longues
absences dues à des maladies purement
web
aujourd'hui comme hier la zénitude au
travail reste un enjeu majeur pour des
entreprises puisque le stress et les
burn out représentent la moitié des
arrêts de travail
[Musique]